let's make crab rangoon start by  shredding our crab here cut this into  small pieces set this to the side let's  make our filling i have eight ounces of  cream cheese one teaspoon of sweetener  some onion teaspoon of garlic powder and  three quarter teaspoon of worcestershire  sauce mix this all up add in some green  onions i'm obsessed with these scissors  they're multi-bladed mix this all up our  crab fold this in doesn't that look so  good you're gonna need some wonton  wrappers and now we're just gonna  connect all the points so i first  connect the top and the bottom and then  i place my finger here and push upward  so i can get out all the air bubbles  pinch it close this side crabbering  goons are all assembled oil is at 375  degrees work in small batches and cook  them for about a minute turning them  over halfway through transfer these guys  onto a paper towel lined plate and voila  crab rangoons crispy and juicy dip them  in a sweet and sour chili sauce  that was so good